they'll face the royals young
flamethrower carlos hernandez well you
know when you know a good starting
pitcher is pitching that day you come to
the ballpark with confidence let's hope
his offense comes with him
altuve ready on the first pitch and
drives one fare down the left field line
jose altuve a leadoff double on a 96
mile an hour fastball and that's how
this series starts carlos correa
gets him to chase a slider at 87 miles
an hour fighting down and away from the
right-handed hitter because jordan
alvarez digs in there he passed the guy
behind the plate salvador perez there's
a ball
roped in the left field for a base hit
al tube around third will score jordan
alvarez gets this game started with an
rbi single to left field you know the
high octane's coming but you bring those
hands through and let that barrel lag a
little bit and shoot it the other way
jake odorizzi on the mound tonight
making his 208th career start number 16
on the year for the houston astros with
picking things up of late is that
batting average up over 270 again
tries to send one to the right side and
does will they get it there in time no
he dropped the baseball that should be a
base hit from airfield that was a real
tough play for guriel and odarizi he now
faces carlos santana
swaying and a miss oder izzy gets him
with a fastball up for a strikeout to
end the inning one hit one man left on
base astros lead one nothing
andrew ben attended will lead off the
bottom of the second
and hits that one
in between the second baseman and
shortstop and directly towards the
umpire and swings here for this guy too
o'hearn slams it to left center field
that ball is going to get down into the
wall ben and tendy roaring around third
he will score and the royals have tied
it and just like you said hud he didn't
try and pull it found success to the
opposite field
that four seamer 106 exit v low he
tagged it look at that very controlled
that's a pretty swing right there
odor is he didn't want to come in but he
had to
and that score has been attending from
first but no problem
emmanuel rivera the batter more than
five or six and that ball lined sharply
to left by rivera so the inning will
continue with merefield coming up
[Applause]
that way we had reached on the infield
hit his first time up stole second base
went to third in the sacrifice but
thrown out at the plate
shallow center it's going to drop and
here comes dozier and the royals playing
the lead on a clutch two out base hit by
with merrifield and now a little slider
that he hits off the end of the bat and
it was perfectly placed here is salvador
perez
tight and for the 15th time this year
salvador perez has walked and the royals
have to lead off man on for the third
straight inning
he does take the base on balls back to
back to open the bottom of the third
inning here's a guy who had a great at
bat last time up and double the left
base hit another opposite field hit for
o'haren and he gives the royals a three
to one lead boy he's just really on he
we made him wait now he put a little
look like a little wrinkle on that but
it'll hurt a little toe trapper there he
didn't load his hips on we go to the
fourth inning carlos correa facing the
heart throwing carlos hernandez
elevate
psych
fine dry base hit off the glove of
whitman maryfield
plumber i think either one of those
pitches would have been better than what
he did
led miss flight out to deep left field
his first time up
that ball's hit well to left field this
ball carrying this ball gone
off the facade of the royals bullpen and
led miss diaz now with an eight-game
hitting streak
with his seventh home run of the year
blasted
talked about how he's a great fastball
hitter he got a fastball right here and
pummeled it on a line
can't sneak the cheese past the lead
miss on her match from super bowl pulls
the hands in gets the barrel to it and
rifles it out
came in at 96 left at 106. jose has
doubled and popped up
now duvet hits it hard into left field
he has a multi-hit game
that is number
37 on the year for jose altuve michael
brantley will bat here oh for two
tonight he's lined out to left and
grounded out to third
up the middle that'll be a base hit to
center field meyers will score easily
we're tied at three rbi base hit by
michael brantley carlos correa leads off
against carlos hernandez in the first
pitch correa belts it deep to left field
and you can't kiss it goodbye
over the bullpen carlos correa gives the
astros a 4-3 lead number 19 on the year
ways lasted batty hit one almost 110
miles per hour that one was crushed as
well heads up if correa gets hot
he can carry a team
sit safely in six of his last seven
games
julie i've been watching
and i think he's he's figured it out
[Applause]
[Laughter]
my goodness just a hanging slider up on
a tee a little bit of wrinkle to it
dozier gets into one blasts it deep into
the night and ties the game
hunter dozier he jumped all over that
little wrinkle there that wrinkle stayed
in the middle slider and he just
barreled it what a beautiful swing that
was this is some of the power right
there
dozers ninth home run
lopez perez santana
yeah ball four
so the royals have their lead off man on
to start the seventh inning in a tight
ball game
runner goes pitch is swung on and missed
throw to second
safe now santana who barely missed a
home run
lopez goes throw to third and almost got
by diaz
as lopez rips off third base
he does get the base hit up the middle
lopez scores and the royals are in front
five to four
taylor jones is going to get a pinch hit
there's a line drive base hits down the
left field line taylor jones pinch
hitting for yard on alvarez heading into
second base with a double
he's a tying run on second with one out
one of the hottest hitters for the
astros lately will stride in there oled
miss diaz
diaz ropes one to left field that's down
for a hit around third comes taylor
jones to throw home cut off work tied at
five diaz caught between first and
second and he will be tagged out to end
the inning but the astros tied at five
in the top half of the eighth inning
with marifield had base hits his first
two times up
and then he gets his third hit well
placed to right field
not yet and
lopez singles up the middle
merrifield charges to third
and look who's coming up now salvi's
coming to the plate and he loves moments
like this
they do pitch to him what else can you
do salvador perez
talk about clutch it's not too
aggressive that's off the plate and
savvy i knew he wasn't gonna be thinking
about a home run here because all he had
to do was do exactly that castro looking
for his first hit he's over three
castro sends the ball to left field well
hit back goes ben and teddy looking up
gone
jason castro opposite field home run
makes it a one-run game it's now seven
to six in the ninth inning harlow must
face
perhaps the most dangerous hitter in
their lineup right now altuve three for
four a pair of singles and a double
popped up right side santana with roon
and the royals win game one of this
four-game series perez the star again
wow what a game this was
great execution by the offense the
bullpen did a nice job
you